The difference between me and Hunter Biden is I did that through the business
that he built up as a capitalist. You know,
if he wanted to give me a billion dollars, I could put it on a pile of floor,
light it on fire. And that's our prerogative. I mean,
that's sort of the differences.
I didn't do it through my daddy's taxpayer funded office.
It seems to me that if Donald Trump Jr was getting about 85 grand a month to
work for a company in a foreign land,
who he didn't have any expertise in doing what they do at LA.
And which I didn't speak in a business, I know nothing about,
I think you see where I'm going with this. I mean,
that's the hypocrisy and the media we're talking about Hunter Biden.
Of course the media loves to do this. They go, Oh, Donald Trump Jr.
Attacked Hunter Biden. I go, yeah, well, daughter was from Jr.
He's so not self-aware. I was like, no, no, no, I get it.
I'm the son of a rich guy.
I've gotten a big part where I set it on Hannity a couple of times.
And then I didn't, you know, give the three minute disclaimer,
the second time I was on. So they were like, Oh, he doesn't get that.
He's also benefited. I go, no, no, I've benefited from my father's last name.
I share his name. I get that. I'm not pretending that it hasn't happened,
but also aren't you proud of that? I mean, a hundred percent,
we have this fear of success here, but Dave,
the difference between me and Hunter Biden is I did that through the business
that he built up as a capitalist. You know,
if he wanted to give me a billion dollars, I could put it on a pilot floor,
light it on fire. And that's our prerogative. I mean,
that's sort of know the difference is I didn't do it through my daddy's tax
payer funded office. Right. Uh, you know,
it magically become an international businessman. When we won,
before he even took the presidency, we said,
we're not going to do new foreign deals. And we had deals that, you know,
buildings we're building and we can't just pull out.
We have a contractual obligation. We said we will not.
That was a big part of my business.
That's why I'm so involved in politics because that's what I did. I got,
I have a lot more free time now. So it was like, Hey,
I'll get involved in this and fight for what I believe in.
It's why I wrote a book, but the false equivalency of being like, well,
how are you different than Hunter Biden? How am I different? Like we start,
I was an international businessman for the last 15 years. Okay.
We stopped doing those deals just so they could have no, you know,
impropriety story,
Hunter Biden magically becomes an international businessmen, you know,
gets on a board of an energy company. He knows nothing about energy,
had no track record and is making $83,000 a month in the Ukraine where his
father is in charge media. No, no, no, no. That's off limits.
I wasn't off limits for two and a half years. Uh, you know,
kids are off limits Baron. Trump's not off limits. They hit him. You know,
Tiffany Trump who's in law school did nothing. You know, just a nice kid,
you know, going to school. She's not off limits.
I wasn't off limits when they spent two and a half years trying to throw me in
jail for treason, for taking a 20 minute unsolicited meeting, Ben Hunter,
Biden's off limits for a shady board seat in a corrupt company.
He's off limits when he takes 1.5 billion from the Chinese government,
not like a Chinese investor from the Chinese government after traveling
there on air force two with his father. Well,
what would the media do if Donald Trump Jr.
Did that show me that they said they didn't talk about it at the golf.
Obviously they didn't mention the business.
They knew nothing about it when they're playing golf together. They, you know,
I just say, do the other thing, how about this? Let's go earlier in life.
Hunter Biden gets a great job at MBNA right out of school happens to be the
largest bank and the largest employer in the state of Delaware,
where Joe is the Senator signing favorable tax legislation. He's brilliant guy.
He's a brilliant guy.
So he manages to rise through the ranks there faster than anyone,
obviously totally a coincidence. He then gets a board seat on Amtrak at 27.
Huge he's a lover of trains. He's a lover of trains, obviously, Dave. I mean,
that's what, that's why he got it.
Nothing to do with daddy controlling the purse strings. No, no, no.
That's off limits.
I haven't talked much about it because honestly it's not even worth it,
but like you get frustrated enough cause they have to tack my personal life.
Everything about it, go, you know, what would happen if Donald Trump Jr.
Got thrown out of the Navy reserve in two weeks, you know,
for doing a little of the AAO, you know, you know, testing positive for cocaine,
you think they'd have a problem. You think that gave me the past.
People don't even hear about that. You know,
turning in a rental car or with a crack pipe and all of these things like that.
And the media would have a field day so much.
So I almost should go do it because if,
when they catch it, they, the real death wish man,
the aneurism that they would have, no, no, no,
it wouldn't be good for us because it would solve the fake news media problem.
Their heads would explode, uh,
without rage that there'd be none left and we could get Mack back to a
reasonable discourse.
So they try to do this false equivalency of what's the difference I go,
that's the difference.
Like Hunter Biden made millions of dollars through his father's taxpayer funded
office has all this other shade in the past and he's totally off limits,
but you had no problem with half of Congress saying that I, you know,
literally committed treason,
a crime punishable by death for taking a 20 minute unsolicited meeting.
But Hillary Clinton can go out, pay foreign agents to go collect dirt,
take that dirt through the DNC, leak it to the FBI,
the SBI then leaks it back to the press. The press writes their outrage story,
which the FBI then uses as the basis of an investigation to
have individuals on a campaign for the president of the United States,
which started the whole Mueller hoax. I mean, where's the outrage,
not even the outrage. Where's the story. Right?
You have like a couple of guys on yo, Sarah Carter, Sean Hannity, Greg Jared,
a couple of guys pointing out. But like,
where's like you think that this would be big news. I mean,
if you're a journalist, like this is kind of a big deal. I mean,
this is a legitimate COO and they're just like nothing to see here.
Nothing going on here, guys,
we're just going to pretend this never happened because it,
it goes against what they would like to happen. It goes against the DNC talkers.
It goes against that media narrative.
And since they've made that cognizant decision to be the marketing wing of the
DNC, we should actually look into them, you know, for, you know,
for campaign finance violations,
because they're just literally contributing millions and billions of free
marketing to the DNC covering for their.
So who in the course of all of this.
I hear you on all of this, who in the course of all this, do you,
and I guess by extension, your dad actually take counsel from.
So I remember during, uh, the Michael Cohen testimony. Yeah.
He was one of the first moments when I was like,
this Russia thing is complete nonsense,
but the reason wasn't because of anything he said,
it was because you were live tweeting it. And I was like, if this guy is guilty,
it meaning you, if you were guilty of anything and our lawyers or everyone,
you know,
would be locking you up and putting you in a room and taking notes because you
were live tweeting. It's so funny.
Oh, it was, it was funny like by lawyers, numerous, like he was like,
you can't do that. Like anything you say, I was like, I don't care. I'm right.
Like, I don't care. This is. And I'm going to say it like, so,
I mean,
I literally had that conversation that sat down with my lawyers numerous.
I'm like, you're in, I go, you guys are making one critical mistake.
If I sit down,
if I just sit in the corner and curl up in a ball and die or you know, cry,
sucking my thumb in the fetal position, that's what they want. Like,
you think they're going to go any lighter on me.
They're not Adam Schiff was on TV every day saying I committed treason.
And he seen evidence to the entire country. You see evidence of trays and,
and collusion and all like, I still haven't seen it. You know what I mean?
You think if he's seen it, no one else has like you think, Hey,
maybe it's time to drop it right now. Like it wasn't in the Mueller report.
But so I'm saying I'm just not going to do it, man.
I'm not going to just sit back. I get where you're going from a legal strategy.
I'm not naive to that. It's not that.
It's the right thing to do. I'm just saying I'm not.
You know, I'm not, I get where they're saying, I go, I just don't care.
And honestly, at the end of it, there go, you know what? You were right.
You needed to push back. Cause you could see it. I mean,
when there I'm in closed door testimony with the house intelligence committee,
right. And I come back,
I'm out of this thing after nine hours or so of testimony,
I get out at seven o'clock at night.
And I look at Twitter and CNN at 1159, Donald Trump Jr.
Was saying this, I go, Jesus Christ. I mean,
Adam Schiff is taking bathroom breaks and leaking this stuff. Door closed, door,
closed door. It was supposed to be totally like, and I go back and say,
I'm looking back. Seven hours in advance. Every time we took a bathroom break,
CNN is breaking this stuff. I mean,
three of their big bombshells had to do with me now. They were all wrong.
They were all false. You know, one of them was the, the WikiLeaks,
like some random dude, like literally DME or send me an email, like,
have you seen this? You know, it was like, whatever, like,
let's call it June 14th right now. They leaked the stuff to CNN.
And I'm looking at the dates. They look, do you have comments on it?
It was June 4th. I was like, Holy. Like they deleted the one in 14.
Right? So the 14 you delete the one, it becomes four.
So the thing broke on like June 10th or whatever it was. Right.
So it looks like I had this information from some random,
there it's a Trump voter.
He donated like 25 bucks and some help like spammed our email.
So like actually like hit my email. So it got there. I didn't respond. I didn't,
but it looked like that. And based on the lead email,
like I had it six days before,
rather than four days after the rest of the freak in the world,
no different than sort of, you know,
meet outing the whistleblower after it's been out there in the public four days,
I'm just like, Oh my God, no bombshell Donald Trump Jr. Had it. I'm like,
here's the toilets. Here's the emails saying,
how come we're the only ones being transparent? Like
you ever get a call so many, not even a retraction on some of these, the other,
you know, Michael Cohen was there when Donald Trump Jr said, no,
his lawyer pulled that one,
his Lilly or pulled it back because they got it wrong.
And they're the guys leaking it. Like it's so asinine. Like, you know,
and then they questioned about now there was no questioning about him.
Then literally perjuring himself. I think it was eight or nine times.
Cause I'm willing to do it. I'm like, Nope, didn't happen. Check X, Y, Z.
I mean, you know, Jim Jordan, some of those called it out.
They sent that thing back to the DOJ. Be like, Hey, what about this?
Not that we're not playing the same game. And that's the problem. I mean,
there are some Republicans that are doing it.
There's some that are learning from Trump because Trump has taught conservative,
Hey, you know, you could fight back.
You don't just have to lose because they want you to,
you don't just have to give up because they're going to write a bad story about
you. Like, but you know what the problem is, that mentality is still there.
It's like, okay, well, you know, we're just, we're going to leave this again.
They would never give us that same benefit of the doubt. I say, Hey,
we can all play T-ball or we can all play hardball,
but we gotta be playing the same game. And we're not,
if you're looking for more, yeah.
Honest and thoughtful conversations about politics instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.